In countries like Japan where most people still identify with Buddhism and the native Shinto religion,...
...the usual trappings of Christmas are a sidenote.
But there's nothing low-key about one Japanese holiday tradition.
This time of year, Japan goes batty for the Beethoven's masterpiece, "Ode To Joy."
December just wouldn't be the end of the year....
...without the stirring rendition of Beethoven's 9th Symphony.
The music is so beloved here, it is known affectionately as "Daiku,"...
...which literally means number 9.
The Beethoven craze began strangely enough during World War I.
German soldiers being held as prisoners in Japan,...
...staged the very first performance of no. 9 here.
The Japanese liked what they heard...
...and by the mid 20th Century, no. 9 had become a holiday hit.